- [Narrator] If you've
ever seen a commercial
for the Home Depot, you might
be familiar with this tune.
- [Man] It's a good time to be a doer.
- [Narrator] Home Depot and its theme song
have inspired a wave of
videos on social media,
revealing its cultural status
as the go-to home improvement store
for many during the pandemic.
Home Depot is the world's
largest home improvement retailer
with over 2300 stores
across North America.
- What we've seen is
home price appreciation
and housing activity at
unprecedented levels.
And what we know is that when
homes become more valuable
those homeowners are more
willing to spend on them.
- [Narrator] With its
2021 fiscal year sales
larger than both Lowe's
and ACE Hardware combined,
one of Home Depot's biggest advantages
is its foothold in the
professional customer space.
That is electricians,
remodelers, plumbers,
and other home professionals
that place more lucrative orders.
So how exactly has Home Depot
attracted more professional customers
and what other strategies have helped it
become a leader in the home
improvement retail industry?
This is the economics of Home Depot.
- Walking into a Home Depot
you'll see a huge floor space,
dozens of long aisles with
everything from screws
and other hardware to
tools, to major appliances,
garden supplies, doors, windows, toilets,
really any thing you'd need
for a home improvement project.
- [Narrator] A typical
Home Depot store stocks
about 30,000 to 40,000
items throughout the year.
Most locations are around
100, 4,000 square feet.
The scale of the store gives
customers the opportunity
to buy raw materials in bulk
and pick up items quickly.
- They try to be somewhere that you can go
if you're just an individual
trying to fix up
something in your kitchen.
They also try to be a
place that you can go
if you're a contractor
trying to buy lumber
to help renovate somebody's home,
or if you're a plumber
that needs all kinds of pipe fittings.
So they really try to be a good source
on both sides of that equation.
- [Narrator] Home Depot
began when co-founders
Bernie Marcus and Arthur Blank were fired
from a home improvement
company called Handy Dan's.
They wanted to launch
a store that would be
significantly bigger and
cheaper than competitors.
In 1979, they opened their
first two Home Depot locations
in Atlanta.
- [Man] The Home Depot.
- [Narrator] The founders had a vision
for a home improvement retailer
that could be a one stop shop for the DIY
or do it yourself customer.
- [Man] You've never
seen anything like it.
- The home improvement
customer to us is unique.
They're a doer.
That's where that word comes from.
- [Narrator] Since it's
founding Home Depot has grown
into a multi-billion dollar company
that increasingly caters to
the professional contractor,
as well as the DIY consumer.
While many industries like
service and hospitality
took a hit during the pandemic,
Home Depot's revenue continued to grow.
The pandemic fueled a boom in
the home improvement industry.
As people spent more time and
money on remodeling projects.
- Between middle of 2020
and the middle of 2021
there were four straight quarters
where Home Depot grew its sales
by more than 20% year over year
which is a very fast pace for
a large established company.
- [Narrator] Home Depot
says they are seeing
increasing demand for
professional projects
as people feel comfortable
inviting contractors
back into their homes.
- There's been this buildup of projects
that require professionals
that more recently
people have been willing to get to.
And that's sort of led to a
second wind of sales growth.
- [Man] What kind of person
would come here at 5:45 a.m.?
Well there's Carly, a carpenter.
- [Narrator] Home Depot
has positioned itself
to attract more business
from these contractors
and home professionals
particularly ones that place big orders.
- [Man] Everything we do, we do for them.
- [Narrator] In the 2021 fiscal year,
about 50% of its sales
came from pro customers,
even though they made up less
than 10% of its customer base.
In comparison about 20 to
25% of Lowe's total sales
come from pro customers
according to the company.
As a key part of its pro customer strategy
Home Depot has invested $1.2 billion
in expanding its supply chain
and distribution network.
The company says it is building
150 new distribution centers
to help speed up the
replenishment of store shelves
and quickly deliver
purchases to customers doors.
Each facility with some as large
as about 14 professional football fields
can hold a huge amount of inventory
and deliver orders
directly to a project site.
- One thing we know that's
important to our pros
is delivery of product to the job site.
We've shifted our model to a network
of nearly 150 distribution
centers that are engineered
to deliver for those
big and bulky products
that are unique to the Home
Depot and unique to the pro.
Think lumber, think doors,
think windows, think vanities.
We're designing a network
that will deliver those goods
same day or next day to 90% of
the population in our market.
- [Narrator] The home improvement giant's
distribution network works in tandem
with their online strategy,
giving pro customers more flexible options
that better align with busy schedules.
- We're one of the largest
e-commerce retailers
in the country by volume.
When people come to pick up orders
from our lockers or from our service desk
they often shop for more
products in the store.
And so that's an economic
flywheel that our website creates
for our company.
- These possibilities have
really helped the company
grow it sales quite a bit
over the last two years,
sales from e-commerce channels
have gone up by about 100%.
So basically doubled.
- [Narrator] Though Home
Depot has seen a long period
of consistent revenue growth,
the home improvement retail
space remains a competitive
and fragmented market.
- This is a space where customers
are very sensitive to prices.
So if one brand is charging a higher price
for a certain type of equipment
that's something that
buyers could pick up on
and could easily shift
to another retailer.
So Home Depot is definitely very sensitive
to other big chains to
smaller mom and pop stores.
- [Narrator] The industry
is also sensitive
to economic fluctuations
especially with spending trends
tied to the housing market.
- Going back to the great recession
in the financial crisis 10 years ago
that was a very difficult time
for home improvement retailers,
a turbulent period for Home Depot.
In the last couple years
to during the pandemic,
the housing market's been very
strong, certainly a company
that would be in a very different position
if there was some kind of big downturn
in the housing market in general.
(upbeat music)